herkese
Merhaba Hoş geldiniz Öncelikle gerçekten
çok heyecanlıyım böyle dilim sürçerse
Lütfen kusura bakmayın başında birazcık
ezberler ekleyeceğim konuşmanız çok
güzel bir sahne gerçekten yıllarca
hayalini kurduğum bir sahne bu rafın
daha öncesinde Sizin oturduğunuz yerde
pedix konuşmalarını izlerken hep hayal
ediyordum acaba günün birinde Gerçekten
ben de bu sahneye çıkabilecek miyim diye
ve çıktım Şu an buradayım şöyle bir
derin nefes alacağım ve başlayacağım
artık
biliyorsunuz dedik için bu yılki teması
bir fotoğraftır bir soru haksız ince
merak ediyorum Aslında diyetisyenlerle
bağdaştıran ve diyetisyen deyince akla
bir fotoğraftır gelen var mı ellerini
Kaldırabilir mi acaba ya genelde öncesi
ve sonrası de fotoğraf paylaşacağız
bizim meslekte tahmin ettiğim gibi Ne bu
gibi paylaştırıyoruz ben çok
hoşlanmıyorum Açıkçası bu durumdan Evet
ben birazcık Hayatım şu before kısmından
bahsetmek istiyorum ben diyetisyen prydz
Buket çürük Ben nasıl bir diyetisyen
oldum Nasıl bir private Şef oldum ve bu
noktaya gelirken bu iki mesleği nasıl
bir araya getirdim nasıl mesaj at
yollardan geçtim Bunları anlatmak
istiyorum size
Aslında
adamın küçük ilçesinde doğdum Annem
hemşire babam esnaf bilirsiniz sağlık
çalışanlarının hayatları oldukça
yoğundur ve başkalarının hayatlarını
kurtarırken altın'da kendi hayatlarında
birçok şeyi ıskalar
bizdede hastaların tam olarak böyleydi
üzerimizde yardımcı bir ablamız vardım
ve annemin nöbetçi olduğu babamın yoğun
çalıştığı dönemlerde İzo ablamıza öyle
mükellef bir abur cubur Sofrası
hazırladık ki ben bayılıyorum o duruma
hala gözünde Hala yalan söylemeyeceğim
çok seviyorum onları E tabi bu keyifli
fakat Ben Yusuf beslenme stili benim
çocukluk ve ergenlik döneminin kilo
probleminde savaşma neden oldu Sonuç
dediğim gibi 122 Buket
üniversite hazırlık dönemlerinde geldik
tercih yapacağım 122 uyum karar verdim
Ben kesinlikle diyetisyen olacağım
tercih yaptık Haliç Üniversitesi
2016-2017 Pardon Ali Üniversitesi
beslenme ve diyetetik kazandım azmettim
diyor ki ben kesinlikle değilsen
olacağım bu kilo vereceğim mezun
olacağım şahane bir Diyetisyene olacağım
üniversite bitti Ben hala 120 kiloyum
babam orada yazıyor bana etkileyen
vadettiği şeyler verirseniz ben o kilo
vermek için neler veriyor bana Ama yok
bende tık yok Ben yemeği seviyorum devam
bu Mehtap üniversiteyi bitirdik 120 kilo
yüz
biliyorsunuz Türkiye şartlarında 120
kilo 50 beden bir yetişen olmak çok da
mantıklı bir şey değil üniversiteye
bitirmemiz sevincini bir yaşayamadım
Çünkü işsizim
Öz güvenim sıfır gerçekten motivasyon
sıfır Mental sağlığım sıfır yerlerde
benim bir şeyler yapmam lazım Çünkü bir
seni yapamayacağım belli
kilo veremiyorum
Hayatımda en çok tutkulu oldum şeyi
merak ettim Ben kesinlikle mutfağı çok
seviyorum mutfakta olmaktan inanılmaz
mutluyum Bütün günümü geçirsem bakmam o
zaman dedim ki ben kesinlikle açlık
okuyacağım Mutfak Sanatları akademisinde
anne ve babamdan gizli mülakata girdim
kazandım Sonra anneme söyledim Annem
zaten her zaman destekçi bana azıcık
orada mırın kırın etti Sen diyetisyensiz
nasıl açtık istersin diye ama Ahmet'im
Ben açlığı okudum 8 ay bu zorlu bir
eğitim süreci oldukça zorlu bir
gerçekten hayatımın en güzel dönemler
iyiydi
mutfağa inanılmaz seviyordum söylemiştim
zaten
sonrasında bu eğitimin bitmesi sonucunda
bir staj dönemi oluyor ve ben onu okuma
şanslıyım ki Tam da istediğim gibi bir
ekibi Tam da istediğim bir mutfak olan
İtalyan mutfağına girdim dahil O zaman
2000'de yer aldım Gerçekten o yaptım
staj benim yerlerde olan özgüvenimi
inanılmaz etkileri 10 Damlalar oldu ben
kendime güvenmeye başladım Onun
sonucunda karar verdim ailem de
desteğini aldım babamın desteğini aldım
ve ben Adana'ya dönüp kendi işimi
yapmaya karar verdim Kendi işimi
yapacağım
Sen kendine Danışmanlık ofisi mi
açacağım ve insanlara gerçekten kilo ile
ilgili problemlerde çözüm bulacağım
Çünkü onların mesajım gerçekten çok iyi
hissediyorum
şimdi Burada birazcık şu before kısmını
Es vermek istiyorum hayatım Şu dönemi
Bence benim After kısmı olan yani
sonrası kısmına gerçekten çok büyük önce
olduğunu düşünüyorum Ofisi açtım Dört
sene geçti Gerçekten inanılmaz
insanlarla tanıştım inanılmaz
danışmanlık yapan düşmanlıklar verdim
çok güzel ilerliyoruz ama bir şeyler
eksik gidiyor
Evet ama ben de yeni tanıştım Şu an işim
olan en büyük destekçilerinden biri
canlı tanıştık ve canlı sürekli
düşünüyoruz ya bizim yeni bir şey
yapmamız lazım yani farklılık yapmamız
lazım insanlar bu diyeti yaparken
zorlanıyor e yemek yemeyi seven bir
toplumuz Adanalıyız Ne yapacağız o zaman
bizim bu işin içine kesinlikle mutfağa
bir an önce açıp dahil etmemiz gerekiyor
ya düşünüyoruz in O çok açmak için o
kadar kolay bir şey değilmiş bunu hep en
başından beri istiyordum o şu an diyorum
ki iyi ki Tam zamanında olması gerektiği
zamanda açılmış Çünkü çok meşakkatli bir
yol çok zor bir yol Biz kasım 2021'de
mutfağımız açtık açtık ama benim
asistanım yoktu o dönem Ben gündüz hem
Danışan bakıyorum Akşam 3.00 gibi
çıkıyoruz Eşim beni alıyor mutfağa
geçiyoruz yandan böyle Ben yemekleri
yapıyorum işim dağıtıma çıkıyordu
danışanların da şey diyorum benim
hayalimi ısıtan vardı telefona
söylememesi tamamladığında işte diyorum
sizinle ilgilenecek astığımız yazacak
Merak etmeyin bütün her şey benden
döndüm için sıkıntı yaşıyoruz zaten
Hatta danışanların en büyük şikayeti
olan şey de Buket Hanım size
ulaşamıyoruz Bu kez onun Çünkü sürekli
bir koşturmaca halinde hayalin peşinden
gitmeye çalışıyor İyi ki Bu o yolları
geçmişim diyorum gerçekten çok mutlu da
sonrasında
baktığınızda biz bu 21 Kasım ayında şevk
için markasını kurduk dediğim gibi
gerçekten adamın Bence
tekrar hizmet veren kişiye özel beslenme
programı oluşturan bir mutfak oldum ve
çok güzel ilerledi genelde danışanların
şu sözü söylüyor bana ya bu kez ansızın
diyetimi olduğuna emin misin aşırı
lezzetli Yani sürekli bu tebrik ediyor
ve inanın yaptığım tek şey yemeği aşırı
severek yapmam beni hiçbir şekilde
zorlamıyor danışmanlığı seviyorum mutfak
aynı sevgi veriyor bana
Daha
sonrasında da şu an bulunduğumuz konuma
geldik Aslında
Burada birazcık yavaş tamam mı
isteyecekler Ben zaten hızlı konuşacağım
diye düşünüyordum tahmin hızlı konuştum
heyecanlıyım Kusura bakmayın mutfağımız
oldu güzel gidiyor her şey ama yine bir
eksiklik var bir şeyler katmanız
gerekiyor
oğlum farklı paketler olsun farklı
içerikler olsun insanların motivasyonu
kuvvetlendirecek şeyler olsun istedik
bunların hepsini aşama aşama ilerledik
ben şuna gerçekten canı gönülden
inanıyorum bir şey istiyorsanız bu
şekilde oluyor Hani ne zaman oluyor Bunu
bilemiyorum beni her zaman geç oldu Ne
zaman ne istersen hepsi geç oldu hatta
minik bir anda bahsetmek istiyorum
mutfak Hayalim benim hep üniversiteyi
bitirdikten sonra ofisim açtıktan sonra
hemen olmasını istediğim şeydi ama beş
yıl sonra oldu Bir gün eşim eve geldi
Ben hüngür hüngür ağlıyorum yok oluyor
Bunu anlatırken ama başka meslek ama
Mutfağı sevmeyen çok alakası olmayan
insanlar çoktan mutfak açmışlar Ben
sinir oldum ya ben hala açamadım Ben
hala o tutkunun da bu Mutfağı açamadım
işim ona sabretmek etmemişler şeyin
zamanı var ya Gerçekten diyorum şu an
iyi ki şu zamanda Kasım'da açmışız
dönüşler Şahane her şey çok güzel benim
Öyle çok büyük hani size verebileceğim
başarılarım Yok henüz a 27 yaşındayım
bilmiyorum Suna Kıraç'ın kitabını
okudunuz mu ömrümden uzun ideallerim var
diye bir kitabı var Ben o ki de bu çok
seviyorum O kitabın ismi çok seviyorum
gerçekten ömrümden uzun ideallerim var
ve başarmak istediğini daha çok şey var
en büyük hedeflerinden birisi de zaten
mutfakla ilgili sürecin artık
tamamlanması daha da ileriye gitmesi
işte bu noktada şunu da söylemek
istiyorum aslında
yaşarsak bir şekilde hepimiz hayatta bir
Kırılma Noktası olmuştur üzüldünüz
yalnızın sıkıldı bunu kilo konusunda da
söyleyebiliriz Ben Danışan Ama
genellikle sonra niye kilo vermek
istiyorsun sizi buraya ne getirdi bu
işte bir kırılma noktasıdır Aslında
Umarım hepiniz okurum noktasını bir önce
yaşarsınız ve Umarım Konfor olanı
hepimiz dışına çıkar ve gelişmek için
çaba sarfediyor Çünkü insan ancak o
zaman hakikaten zorlandığında bir
şeylere başarı ve elde edebiliyor Tıpkı
Tetik sahnesinde olmak gibi bu gerçekten
büyük bir hayal de yalan söylemeyeceğim
Bütün Gece boyunca çalıştım ama dedim ki
Buket kendim gibi ol zaten Bence o
duyguyu da hissettireceksin dedim yani
hissettiriyor diye düşünüyorum
Çok
teşekkür ederim
şimdi birazcık konuşma böyle yavaş yavaş
bitireceğim konuşmamın sonunda da
açıkçası üç tane görsel hazırlamıştım
dedim ki ben onları da bakmayacağım her
şeyi karıştırıyorum Çünkü
konuşmamın sonunda şans eseri önüme
çıkan Pink floyd'un bir tane sözü vardı
bunu da bir tehdit konuşmasına görmüştüm
çok hoşuma gitti sizinle paylaşmak
istedim şimdi her birinize hayallerinde
kendi yarattığı duvarları samimiyetle
özenle sabırla yapmanızı diliyorum beni
dinlediğiniz için çok teşekkür ediyorum